So the goal for the rest of this unit
is to modify our search engine code to implement
the PageRank algorithm. We have one little problem. PageRank
is a registered trademark of Google. So we're not going to
call our algorithm PageRank, even though it will do
the same thing. We'll call it URank. The first thing
we need to be able to do, to implement
this ranking algorithm, is keep track of the link graph.
So our popularity of pages depends on the link structure. So that means, we need
to keep track of, what pages link to what pages. So, for each link, there is
a connection between pages and we can think
of that, as a graph. Abstractly, a graph
is just a set of nodes, we'll draw
those as circles, with edges between the nodes.
And because our edges go one way, just like
links in a page, we call this a directed
graph. So, in order to represent our web link
structure we need to build the directed graph. The pages
in the graph are the nodes. For each page,
we need to keep track of the edges that connect
that node to other nodes. And so the way
that we're going to do this is to keep a dictionary.
So we're going to have a dictionary where the entries
in the dictionary are the node, which is the URL,
that's the page. And for each URL, we'll have a
list of all the pages that it links to. So
if this was say node a, and these were nodes
b, c, and d, our entry for node a would
contain the list b, c, d. And our entry for
node b, well, there are no edges out of b,
so it would be an empty list. And finishing the example, C has an out link to
one node, and D has no out links. So
that's our goal. We want to build a structure
like this that shows the structure of the
webpages that we crawl, and we see that structure
because we're following the links in our crawler. So
our goal is to modify the crawl web procedure
that we defined at the end of Unit Five. And to
modify it so that instead of just producing an index, it
also produces a graph. So we're going to modify crawl web. It's
going to still take a seed page as its start. But what
it's going to produce now is both an index and a
graph. And the graph is a structure that gives a mapping
from each node to the pages that it links to. So
let's look at the code that we had at the end of
Unit Five and see how we need to change that. So
here's the code, that we had at the end of unit five,
for crawling the web. And as a reminder, we're keeping track
of the pages left to crawl in the list tocrawl starting with
the seed page, and we're building up the index as a
dictionary. And as long as there are pages left to crawl, we
go through the while loop, which finds a page to crawl,
popping the list of pages to crawl. As long as this one,
we haven't crawled before, it gets the content from that
page. It adds it to the index. It finds all the
links, using get_all_links, passing in the content on the page and
unions those with tocrawl to update the tocrawl list and then
it appends this page to the list of pages, that have
already been crawled. So to change this to build a graph,
we're going to keep most of the code the same. In addition
to producing just index, we're going to produce a graph. And the
graph is also going to be a dictionary. And the reason the
graph is a dictionary is that the mapping from nodes, which
are urls, to the list of edges that go out from
that node. So we'll create the graph as an empty dictionary.
And as we find new pages, we're going to add them to
the graph. And we're going to also change the return to return
both the index and the graph. I'm going to make one more
change before we give you a quiz. And the change I'm
going to make is, instead of calling get_ all_links here,
Since both the graph building and the tocrawl list depend
on knowing all the links, we're going to create a
new variable. And we'll assign the result of get_all_links(content) to
that variable. That means we can use those links
as the input to content. But we can also use
them to build the graph. And I'm going to leave
the line that we need to build a graph for
you to complete. So we'll make that a quiz, to finish
this code. Write the line that we need to update the graph.